et chacun bonsoir merci d'avoir réservé
cette visite à notre journal on va tout
de suite parlé de la nouvelle patricia
kaas l'album ça on va en parler un
instant on va parler également tout de
suite du nouveau look puisque vous
faites la une de tous les magazines qui
soit femina ou même les magazines
d'information alors ça correspond à quoi
ce changement ça correspond à plein de
choses ça correspond à un changement de
vie parce que quand on a 30 ans 20 en ce
sens différemment et puis je sais pas il
ya deux ans j'avais je sais pas j'avais
envie j'ai en fait à un magazine j'ai vu
une fille et des cheveux blonds l'aide
et je me suis dit j'essaye et j'ai
essayé j'ai aimé puis j'ai pas j'ai pas
voulu changer de look pour cet album
c'est à dire que j'ai pas voulu qu'il ya
un décalage entre l'artiste et le
personnage comme ça a pu être parent
avant parce qu'on passe par des moments
où on est un peu perdu on passe par des
moments cherche un peu et là je crois
que aujourd'hui je suis un peu j'ai plus
confiance en moi et je suis plus
moi-même
et donc voilà donc ce changement est lié
à 30 ans 1
j'ai pas tout ce qui s'est passé dans ma
vie plein de choses
en tout cas ça vous va très bien merci
alors parlons maintenant l'album qui est
très nouveau suis celui-là 13 types
choisi au milieu de plusieurs centaines
de propositions vous avez fait de
musique notamment avec des auteurs comme
goldman barbelivien bergman et il ya
surtout une voix
j'ai écouté un peu différente - rock - -
dietrich comme vous le faisiez il ya
quelques années encore moi je me rend un
peu moins content parce que ce qui a
déjà des chansons sur lesquelles je
donne plus de bouaye des chansons
effectivement il ya plus de retenue et
ce qui se passe c'est que déjà je sais
mieux l'utiliser ces deux voies et parce
que je la connais mieux et ensuite je
vais diriger sur cet album je sais que
voilà pression justement vous prenez les
choses de plus en plus en main vous
aimez - quand vous dirigez vous prenait
vraiment votre votre carrière en main
parce que j'ai plus d'expérience avance
est pas qu on me laissait pas c'est
qu'il y avait des choses que je pouvais
pas décider parce que je connaissais pas
et aujourd'hui ben c'est vrai que je
m'implique de plus en plus et je me
rends compte que
en fait on s'est mieux ce qui est bien
pour soi et on peut mieux le faire
content que ce soit mais alors je ne
vais plus faire de comparaison comme
certains avec des touches chanteuse
parce que vous avez passé le k de
ressembler à quelqu'un vous êtes décidé
à bercy cela dit vous avez bien
l'intention de faire une très grande
carrière internationale notamment
maintenant du côté des états unis cet
été vous enregistré en anglais pourquoi
cette tentation des ethnies on ne peut
pas être une grande chanteuse uniquement
ici en europe il faut c'est un pari un
challenge
non je dirais que c'est un rêve mais
c'est un rêve qu'on partage avec qu'on
peut pas réaliser seul et j'ai senti ma
maison disque américaine prête prête à
travailler pour une artiste française et
je veux dire c'est quand même un pays
qui est très loin ils sortent plein
d'artistes tout le temps et j'ai pris
vraiment comme une chambre c'est vous
pouvez y arriver je sais pas je il y
avait une seule voix la bei avait il y
avait cette question qui était de
chanter en anglais donc j'ai dit écoutez
si on fait pas de moins quelqu'un
d'autre si je peux garder mes émotions
et le penser en france eh ben voilà
et voilà et puis bon ben on va foncer on
va voir ce que ça donne alors quatre ans
enregistré cent enregistrée mais avec
des tournées dans le monde entier
notamment dans les pays de l'est vous
avez été très bien très bien accueilli
ce que vous aimez vous par dessus tout
c'est la scène parce que par rapport à
d'autres jeunes artistes vous avez déjà
une très longue expérience d'au moins 10
ans de scène avant d'enregistrer que ce
soit oui j'ai commencé par la scène j'ai
commencé avec le contact du public qui
ça c'est la meilleure école parce que
peu importe quelle condition n'a pas
peur et ça ça aide quand même beaucoup
mais je connaisse ce sentiment même si à
l'époque ce n'était pas la même chose
les gens venaient pas forcément pour
mouvoir - est née pour s'amuser pour
rigoler enfin pour danser et là je
pourrai pas sortir un album sans faire
de spectacle j'ai besoin du contact avec
le public et même si j'aime le studio
est important parce que on a même des
choses nouvelles
voilà alors vous avez à peine 30 ans
déjà 17 ans de carrière
est ce que peut encore vous parler de de
vos débuts est ce qu on peut évoquer vos
débuts est ce que vous y pensez encore
with an mais non d'un soir qu'est ce qui
m'est arrivé un petit pansement
je pense souvent est ce que vous avez
envie de retourner dans ce cabaret
comment s'appelait-il rommel kama ouais
mais il existe des allez voir il est
vous asseoir la base dire que j'en ai
fait du chemin
mais j'y pense surtout bon comme comme
là on en parle donc effectivement il des
images qui reviennent et c'est ça a été
des moments des baux de bons moments
donc ça s'oublie pas et vous y pensez
souvent merci
patricia kaas d'avoir réservé cette
première visite à notre journal je
rappelle le titre de cet album dont qui
sort demain dans 44 pays ça c'est un
vrai lancement international
bon ma chère pathé chacun merci beaucoup
de nous avoir rendu visite et puis à
bonne chance pour ce cd et puis pour la
suite de votre taille
merci